[grunting and moaning]
- DESPITE MY EXTREME DISCOMFORT
WITH CASUAL SEX,
I WAS DETERMINED
TO GET INTO THE MIX.
AFTER ABOUT AN HOUR,
I CAME TO ACCEPT
THAT I WOULD NEED
TO REMOVE MY CLOTHING.
BUT EVEN THAT DID LITTLE
TO AROUSE ME OR ANYONE ELSE.
THE IRONWORK
ON THIS STAIRCASE IS...
REMARKABLE.
HEY, LISTEN,
I THINK WE NEED TO DECIDE
WHETHER THIS IS A SNACK TABLE
OR ANOTHER SEX SURFACE.
BECAUSE I REALLY DON'T
THINK IT CAN BE BOTH, YOU KNOW?
YOU KNOW, TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH,
THERE IS NO PLACE
THAT I FEEL COMFORTABLE
SETTING DOWN THESE SNACKS.
IT SEEMED I WAS INCAPABLE
OF GETTING IN THE SPIRIT.
BUT THEN I MET
THE KING OF THE ORGY.
- THIS IS YOUR FIRST TIME
AT AN ORGY, YES?
- YOU KNOW--YES, ACTUALLY.
THAT'S RIGHT, YES, TH--YEP.
THIS IS MY FIRST ORGY.
- YOU MUST EMBRACE
THE POWER OF THE MASK
TO TRANSFORM YOU FROM WHOEVER
YOU ARE OUT THERE,
INTO A GLORIOUS [bleep] BEAST
WHO IS BORN
WHEN YOU WALK IN HERE,
AND WHO DIES WHEN YOUR BALLS
ARE FULLY DRAINED.
- THAT WAS THE ATTITUDE
ADJUSTMENT I'D NEEDED.
I THINK I CAN DO THAT.
I CAN BE A [bleep] BEAST.
I WAS FREED FROM FORREST
MACNEIL'S SELF-CONSCIOUSNESS
AND HIS FEARS OF BEING PERFECTLY
AVERAGE IN THE PENIS DEPARTMENT.
WHO WANTS TO HAVE SEX WITH ME?
[shrill yelp]
LET'S KEEP THIS FELLA-TIONSHIP
STRICTLY BLOW-FESSIONAL.
I'M ASKING FOR ORAL SEX.
THE BARRIERS
I HAD PUT UP BETWEEN MYSELF
AND WILD SEXUAL ABANDON
WERE WASHED AWAY
IN A TIDAL WAVE OF PLEASURE.
AND I HAVE TO SAY,
IT WAS ONE OF THE GREATEST
[bleep] NIGHTS OF MY LIFE.
I'M A [bleep] BEAST!